please to have here on the Rich Eisen
show for the first time a guy but I was
able to meet for a few years before I
departed ESPN where he was for 15 years
before joining the New York Times been
covering the NBA since 1994 he's our
friend Mark Steyn how are you mark good
that's what so let's dive into this year
how did this all come together
how long is Kauai been courting Paul
George to your estimation well basically
the whole week of free agency is when he
zeroed in on Paul George you know he he
didn't start there
he made a run at Jimmy Butler first and
that was that was going on even during
the playoffs and he also explored Kevin
Durant Kevin would you come to the
Clippers with me I mean he we've known
the Clippers have wanted Kawhi Leonard
for a long time but Kawhi wanted to be
joined by an elite level player and it's
not I'm not trying to suggest that that
Paul was his third choice
they're obviously friends and he loves
Paul George but Paul George wasn't
gettable he has three more years on his
contract to before a player option so
you wouldn't have targeted Paul George
first because even Kawhi Leonard
wouldn't have thought he's available but
Jimmy Butler wanted to go to Miami
Durant obviously was very far down the
road and going somewhere with Kyrie
Irving and that became Brooklyn so quite
a flex to to go to Paul George in those
circumstances and say go ask for a trade
come to the Clippers with me I really
you know we've seen we've seen players
come up we've seen player two player
plotting and recruiting but that is this
is a new one
it sure is cuz there's so much time left
on Paul George's contract and I mean
what a contracts mean in the NBA Marc I
guess is the writ large question here if
somebody can re-sign like Paul George
did and then all of a sudden stroll and
say I want out and he gets out I mean
what does this mean it's one of the most
complex
issues that the league face and in in my
time certainly and there are 50 sides to
the coin and there is no blanket answer
because the look this all started in
2010 when the heels came together and
that really started the player power era
and as we all know LeBron James is the
foremost flexor in that era but the
league's position has always been we
cannot police player contact unless
there is evidence that the players are
acting on direct instruction from their
GM if the Clippers are you know if you
know in this case Kawhi Leonard was
trying to bring Paul George to a team he
was not but like like in in a 16 we know
the Warriors were a month forward
pushing for Kevin Durant if there's
evidence that the Warriors front office
is telling draymond Green a lot in a
call to Kevin Durant today if there's
evidence of that then that's where it
becomes quote tampering but if this is
player two player contact the league is
always taking this position that we
can't we can't police that we can't know
when the two buddies just talking about
their futures together or when it's more
than that and you know but look the
owners are meeting this week in Vegas
summer league I mean this is obviously
going to be a massive point of
discussion because again this is this is
you know Kevin Durant was in his last
year of a deal in 2016 not you know this
is you know as you just said you know
Paul George has he was one year into a
new deal and that's what makes this so
different and for small market teams
very demoralizing I mean is incredibly
demoralizing sit cut so watch this so
mark Stein of the New York Times here
was there no chance of Sam Presti just
telling Paul George too bad I mean just
too bad you know you're here we love
that you're here the the mayor
proclaimed it Paul George day for crying
out loud
when Yuri signed I mean they're there
there's no sense in front offices in the
NBA of telling players who have long
term contracts left essentially what the
NFL tells players too bad I think he
wanted to no question I think you know
with the moves they made you know that
you you can tell the Thunder we're not
expecting this to happen but Sam Presti
is also a very smart guy I think he had
to step back and say we've just lost in
the first round two years in a row we
have no flexibility in the short term to
make significant changes to our team
this is basically our team we're gonna
have to run it back with Paul George
coming off double sole shoulder surgery
let's not forget Russell Westbrook
Stephen Adams a CEO they say look
they're trying to move atoms they didn't
really make any inroads there so do you
bring the same team back in this crazy
West where everyone is loading up and
it'll be even deeper next season
probably as a you know as the top to
bottom conference than it already was or
you do what Sam Presti did and extract
the big haul we've ever seen anyone
player set in a trade history and the
reason that it happened is because the
Thunder knew or not just trading Paul
George we're true we're trading them
Kawhi Leonard as well Kawhi Leonard was
not an Oklahoma City player but the
Clippers no weak the Clippers gave up
everything because they knew they're
getting them both and look at what the
Thunder got they had to do it it's not
even a question or unprotected first one
protected first to pick swaps and two
very good players I mean go back in
history and look at you know look at
what
Kareem abdul-jabbar what was involved in
that trade and and you know even the
Barclays trade 20 years later I mean
they got so much they had to do it marks
down here on the Rich Eisen show so
let's talk about the the dominoes still
tumbling Jeremy grant sent off today by
Presti for another first rounder to
Denver's
Dean gets even more strong in a dynamite
Western Conference is Westbrook next is
it possible that they press I mean he
might as well just raise it all down to
the ground right now mark right there
looking into it there's a sense that
Westbrook may or may not want to go at
this point I mean I don't know that we
have a clear handle on exactly how he
feels about all this you know on one
hand I'm sure Westbrook wants to get
somewhere where he can be in the
championship mix because the Thunder
right now aren't but he's also been in
Oklahoma City for a long long time and
there is you know a tight bond between
Westbrook in that community so I mean
look the overriding issue here is
Westbrook just has a gargantuan contract
that's not easy to trade in his last
year that CEO is making almost 50
million so it's not easy to move him you
know but again I think we've seen that
when when when the Thunder has to make
tough decisions they're not afraid to
make them so if they're if a market
emerges for Westbrook don't doubt the
fan prep you would do it well how could
the Knicks not be a market for him I
mean they got to be desperate right now
Marc right I certainly would happen with
the nets the Clippers just did what the
Knicks hope to do the Nets did with the
the Knicks hope to do which is add two
stars with all that cap space there
wouldn't you think the Knicks right now
would be desperate to say hey we got
Westbrook don't forget us on on seventh
Avenue
well they certainly whisk I mean they
they you know the Knicks the Knicks are
the ones that raised expectations here
you know Jim Dolan came out in the radio
interview they wrote a letter to see
some ticket holders in April after that
they're the ones who promised big things
and creatively and obviously did not
work out but saying all that look where
the Knicks really are there's their
group their team is so young in its
development that even if you bring
Westbrook in you know they still are a
ways away from really competing so if
you are the
are you gonna take on that kind of
contour there a team that is positioned
to do so they could do it but are they
going to do that without assurances that
they would have other star players who
they could plug in there I'm not so sure
so why couldn't Kauai and Paul George I
guess I guess the you know Los Angeles
was the draw with the Clippers as
opposed to the Knicks oh I'm trying to
just figure out is you know you went on
DP show last week mark and talked about
how Jim Dola needs to look in a mirror I
said the same thing I said it's time to
take the car keys away from him in the
same way that that what happened with
the Clippers would never have happened
if Donald sterling was there and I know
the reason why he's not there is no is
not even as I said to earlier sterling
makes James Dolan look like Branch
Rickey my question to you is it does
does he look in the mirror does that
actually happen is that in fact I can
tell it won't it won't and there's no
one who can make it happen you know
that's that who's going to make it
happen you know it can can pressure from
the other shareholders who have faked it
who have a stake in the Knicks can they
exert some level of pressure I I suppose
that's possible but you know you
mentioned Donald sterling the the first
team I ever covered in this league was
the Clippers Donald sterling did years
and years and years and years of
egregious things and they couldn't get
him out they couldn't get him out until
he did something so egregious that
finally the NBA had the ability to push
him out of the league but before that he
did so many things that were
reprehensible and got away with it
you know Jim Dolan is you know his you
know crimes is the wrong word his
transgressions whatever these are it's
just the way he runs his team there's no
way to push him out and he's gonna have
the self-awareness to say you know what
I might be hindering our efforts here I
mean there's no evidence about if he
does I mean might use different words
than that that's a very New York Times
way to put it mark so can you give voice
to what the Clippers just pulled off
here in Los Angeles then mark I tried my
best at the top of the show about the
the deck
of clipper nation just waiting just
waiting to beat within the area code of
footing of the Lakers and they got close
with Paul George and DeAndre Jordan and
Blake Griffin with Doc Rivers a couple
years ago there they're right there now
mark I mean it's gonna be amazing in
Staples this fall can you get voice to
the Clipper nation having obviously
covered them here's the thing though I
think you've lived there long enough now
to know that as seismic as these moves
are and I cry shouldn't use that word
after which it happens right it's
massively yes as epic as these moves are
like if the Lakers the Lakers presence
in that city is still so huge that it's
going to take it's not just the moves
it's gonna have to lead to real success
but what I would say is the Clippers
front office that what what see Vollmer
has done the resources he's given the
people who work there to go out and do
what they just did and they're gonna
keep making moves and you know you in
the long term you've got you know I bet
on them to find a way to win a
championship they're not there yet but
these are two two obviously just huge
huge moves that there's it is the most
significant era transactions in
franchise history and what makes it so
great is that these guys are all in the
same building playing doubles against
each other when LeBron and 80 against
Kawhi and Paul George is in one building
delicious but it's not enough to just
it's not going to be enough now my
question is if Kawhi proves to be the
best player out of the four and at this
point he just might be he was so so good
in behind the playoff if he proves to be
the best out of the four next season
that will be very interesting but but
again we can't it's the same thing with
the Knicks in the net the net just punch
Big Brother right in the face and you
know the net I mean you're the Lakers
still have LeBron and AD the Knicks the
next
in a way left Nick's in the dust here
but it's if New York is still so
overwhelmingly the Knicks territory but
to even two big moves is not enough so
before I let you go Mark Steyn give me
an insider's glimpse of what the owners
are gonna be talking about when they see
this cuz obviously everyone is talking
about how great NBA free agency is and
discussing the Western Conference the
Eastern Conference it's now it's now you
know more level playing field but it
appears to be in this league that you
need to amass as many stars as possible
it's still a super team League you don't
have three in any place but you have to
and if you don't have the ability to get
one or two you're gonna take which one
you ever have and just trade them off
for as many first-round picks and hope
that your fan base buys that and that
you use that to build a team like that
seems to be the two ways to go about
business now in the NBA when it all
comes down to it is the league happy
with this development you know I think
the league office would probably you
know if they were as candid as we would
like them to be they couldn't be unhappy
with the interest in the league and also
this is another reason why it's so this
is so tough you can point to some small
market teams who are doing really well
Utah Indiana Denver these things have
been very well managed and you know Utah
Indiana has made great moves this summer
very quietly far under the the Kawhi
Paul George level but like those who
have gotten better but then if you I
mean imagine running the Milwaukee Bucks
right now I mean you oh you just want
this you you are now if they are right
now in the Anthony Davis zone where they
have to wait till next summer before
Yanis can sign a contract extension and
I'm sure there you know there is nervous
as they've ever been wondering what
stars are going to be trying to talk be
honest to convince him to leave now
Yanis seems you he is just constantly
given the empress'
and that he loves Milwaukee he wants to
make he wants to bring a championship to
Milwaukee he said I'm never leaving but
you know how much comfort does that
really give the Bucks I mean you saw
they just struck a deal to bring his
older brother in which was smart I mean
you got to do everything to try to make
your superstars happy because there's no
sport in the world no team sport in the
world
where one guy makes a difference like
they do in basketball and that's why
everybody wants these guys because one
player like this changes your Fort Smith
so dramatically mark great stuff as
always love reading your material here
in your wherever you appear and I
appreciate you appearing on this show
hopefully first of many times thanks out
good you bet that's mark Stein at the
Stein line for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app